So we were seeing more and more of this pejorative
use of the term Chinese virus from Donald
Trump to refer to the Corona virus, that's
bad enough and it's growing daily.
Donald Trump seems to sort of be getting energy
from it and really enjoying using it.
But we're also now hearing from an Asian reporter
that a Trump official referred to the virus
as the Kang flu to her face.
We're talking about Wagih Yang Jang, who is
a CBS News White House correspondent.
She tweeted yesterday that quote, This morning,
a White House official referred to Corona
virus as the Kang flu to my face.
Makes me wonder what they're calling it behind
my back.
Meanwhile, again, Donald Trump seems to have
realized that Chinese virus is working well
for him in terms of propaganda and currying
favor with his supporters.
And he's constantly tweeting about it.
Now, just in the last few hours, Donald Trump
tweeted, quote, I always treated the Chinese
virus very seriously and have done a very
good job from the beginning, including my
very early decision to close the borders from
China, as well as saying this morning, I will
be having a news conference today to discuss
very important news from the FDA concerning
the Chinese virus.
And then an hour before that, for the people
that are now out of work because of the important
and necessary containment policies.
For instance, the shutting down of hotels,
bars and restaurants.
Money will soon be coming to you.
The onslaught of the Chinese virus is not
your fault.
Now, there are people saying we should call
it the Chinese virus because the Spanish flu
was called the Spanish flu.
And we call things what they are.
Even that assessment ignores history.
The 1918 flu, sometimes called the Spanish
flu, didn't start in Spain and it didn't really
have anything to do with Spain.
The Spanish flu started in either Kansas,
France or China.
It was called the Spanish Flu by the allies
in World War One because it got more attention
when it moved from France to Spain in November
of 1918.
In the same way, if anything, we would be
calling this the European flu because it became
more quickly prevalent around the world once
it got to Europe.
And that really became the epicenter.
It did originate in China.
China had an explosion of cases now under
control in China.
Europe is really the focus of the worldwide
spread.
If things continue as European countries get
under control to explode in the U.S., this
may soon be the U.S. flu, the U.S. virus,
by the way.
But in any case, you know, when you start
hearing things like Kong flu, Chinese virus,
you know, you're losing the fight against
the virus and you're instead choosing to fight
a propaganda war.
And the reality is, wherever it started, like,
listen, if the governor of Oklahoma is bragging
about going out to restaurants when we should
be self isolating, it doesn't matter whether
it's started in China, France, Italy, Australia
or Peru.
It just doesn't matter.
We are spreading it here and we are causing
the problem to get even worse.
And that's ultimately what matters.
And at the rate things are going.
And from the EMA, I'm actually I actually
got a message yesterday from someone who said
someone I know's roommate is just pretending
like nothing's going on.
They're just going about their day.
They're annoyed that their favorite restaurants
are takeout only and they think the entire
thing is just a hoax.
That's here in Massachusetts.
Just imagine what is going on and how prevalent
that is in a red state like Oklahoma, where
the governor is publicly minimizing it and
bragging about being with his kids out to
dinner at a packed restaurant.
We're just not going to solve it if that's
the case.
And people will die unnecessarily.
This is not, you know, lying about I cut the
deficit when you didn't.
That's bad enough.
But this this is life and death for a lot
of people.
And every single day, the death toll is climbing.
And it's not slowing down, unfortunately.